die berliner modewoche ist vorbei die
bilanz ist eher gemischt diesmal fehlten
die höhepunkte großen marken waren nicht
da boß dort die schumacher mich halt die
escada wichtige deutsche modemacher
haben sich zurückgehalten oder sie
schade weil die natürlich auch die große
anziehungskraft haben
positiv muss man sagen dass es viele
gute inszenierung gab es gab schauen zum
beispiel von schulämtern wo die models
über eine baracke gelaufen bin
es gab alte industriegebäude es gab
viele schöne kleine präsentationen
etabliert hat sich auch der berliner
salon und der vogue salon die
gemeinsamen stattfinden
das sind sehr gute show cases für kleine
designer wo man sozusagen per speed
dating ganz viele neue marken kennen
lernen kann und das ist eine sehr schöne
format für berlin weil es eben
reflektiert dass viele designer nicht
groß auftrumpfen können aber laien und
direkt das publikum ansprechen kann
es gab neue entdeckungen wie youtube
oder working titel sehr gute kleine
marken die auf handarbeit setzen auf
nachhaltigkeit setzen die wirklich die
mode nach vorne bringen in berlin
was das große publikum oft nicht sieht
sind die messen die parallel stattfinden
wie zum beispiel ist die premium wo sehr
viel los ist große veranstaltung die
sehr viele einzelhändler modemacher und
auch neue marken anziehen und david auch
geschäft gemacht da wird gehandelt und
da sieht man sozusagen das deutsche dass
er nämlich die mode nicht over the top
sondern auch für den kunden macht
die designer lassen sich nicht
unterkriegen sie machen weiter
horn versuchen ihre marken aufzubauen
sie wissen dass berlin nicht paris ist
und suchen das glück in der nische und
das das beste machen können die großen
erwartungen sind enttäuscht worden das
macht aber nichts die modewoche wird es
immer geben es gibt viele deutsche
designer wie diesen das anbietet weil
sie ein deutsches publikum erreichen
aber wir natürlich noch höher hinaus
will der international gelten will der
wird dann doch nach paris gehen lassen
wer jetzt enttäuscht war sollte sich
nicht abhalten lassen im sommer wieder
zu kommen denn da wird bestimmt melo
sind
[Musik]